on a dark night 12 years ago somewhere
in the East blue a young kid is trapped
in a cage on a ship that is sailing away
from his home Islands he's shouting and
Swinging his fist at anyone in reach but
the crew is too strong to care then a
figure in a long green clo walks up
kneels in front of the child and pulls
back his hood the Furious child launches
a punch but the man with the mysterious
tattoo easily blocks it and pulls the
child tight against the bars where are
you taking me the child screams and all
the mysterious man says is to your new
home the child is monkey deffy and the
man he is the most wanted man in the
world and the child's father Monkey D
Dragon which of course means that even
though Luffy would probably still fight
and scream the entire Voyage in this
what if scenario there is literally
nothing he can do to stop his father
from taking him to the Revolutionary
Army Headquarters to raise him as a
revolutionary and wow I mean this is
absolutely going to be completely
changing Luffy's life in basically every
way imaginable some of which are really
bad as we'll see and surprisingly some
of them are incredibly awesome first off
though let's be real Luffy wouldn't care
even one bit that dragon is actually his
father I mean when he originally learned
about his father he didn't care at all
either and I do think that the same
would be applying here but once they get
back to the Revolutionary army base I do
think that Luffy's attitude will
eventually start changing a bit because
at this point dragon's group of Freedom
Fighters is full of people that Luffy
became friends with later on anyways
like this huge cyborg guy who saved
Luffy at the end of sabot plus of course
Ivanov here who literally saved Luffy's
life during the prison break before the
war at Marine Fort so knowing Luffy he
will probably start to make friends and
be happy here pretty quickly because if
you remember from his original flashback
Luffy truly just wanted to have some
friends to hang out with all along so
maybe coming to his father's base might
actually have been a good thing I mean
he'll definitely find some way better
mentors than the band of mountain
Bandits here but that's of course only
the start of things because you will not
believe how much stronger revolutionary
Army Luffy is actually going to become
first of all we all can assume that
Dragon does know hockey of course so
he'll definitely teach Luffy the basics
as he grows up quite a lot earlier so
basically we can add Armament and
observation hockey to Young Luffy's
Arsenal plus there are also other
characters with devil fruits at the
revolutionaries base so they might be
able to help Luffy Master his powers a
lot faster since he didn't really know
anyone else with the devil fruit back on
his home islands and on top of that
there are also other fighting styles
that Luffy could learn here for example
this revolutionary fishermen is a master
of the so-called fisherman karate which
is used by the fishermen to control
water but is also an extremely strong
Marshall Arts form in general there's
also ivanov's new K kimple which Sanji
mastered during the time skip so really
this version of Luffy is going to have
way more training and fighting
techniques than he did in the original
story but don't worry things are about
to get even more crazy because when
Luffy was 8 years old there was another
super important child that Dragon
actually rescued and brought to the
Revolutionary base and of course I am
talking about Sabo here who originally
grew up with Luffy and Ace in the forest
of his home Island however once he
learned just how awful the rulers of the
Kingdom were in luding his parents he
decided to flee the kingdom to start a
life at Sea as a pirate unfortunately
for him he was basically immediately
sunk by a world Noble ship and was
rescued by Dragon here and then raised
as a revolutionary so add an ally to the
party here because Luffy is now going to
have a new best friend from his own home
islands and I mean you can just imagine
the fun and trouble let's be real that
these two would get into running around
the Revolutionary army base they might
even destroy the entire thing if we're
being honest but not only that they'd
also have a super important role to play
in each other's lives going forward you
see after sabba was blown up he had lost
all his memories and completely
forgotten his life at the Goa Kingdom
however that's all going to change here
because I can just imagine when Luffy
mentions that he was from the Goa
Kingdom that Sabo most likely would
regain those memories that he had lost
at this point and although that wouldn't
include his time growing up with Luffy
because remember that didn't happen in
this scenario Sao would very much
remember Ace which is going to play a
major role as you can imagine in just a
minute in fact once he does regain his
memories Sabo might desperately want to
go back to the Goa Kingdom or at least
send a message to let Ace know that he
is in fact still alive and they might
even try to convince Ace to even join
the revolutionaries but for now we're
going to leave Ace to follow his regular
path to becoming a pirate and then
joining Whitebeard now at this point you
might be wondering why Dragon wanted to
bring Luffy here in the first place and
and while there could of course be many
reasons including him just trying to be
a decent father who once the one that
makes the most sense sadly to me is that
Dragon might actually know the true
secrets of Luffy's devil fruit Awakening
so when he learns that his son has eaten
those Powers then he will want to raise
Luffy himself to give him the best
opportunity to one day awaken gear five
which is actually the perfect power when
you think about it for a revolutionary
Freedom Army but for now back to child
Luffy here perhaps the most game
changing thing about Luffy growing up
with dragon is that there is no way that
his father can keep them on the island
forever and So eventually Sao and Luffy
would be taken out on missions all over
the world at a probably fairly young age
and during this time both of these boys
and this revolutionary girl will learn
so so much about the world because if
we're being honest originally Luffy had
literally zero formal education and knew
nothing about the world but now he would
very likely learn about different
kingdoms the races of the world and
probably even really really practical
stuff like how to actually sail a ship
which we do all know that he never
learned that skill in the current
storyline and on top of all that they
would learn about the world government's
oppression and dark secrets along with
the Revolutionary Army's true goals of
taking down the world Nobles now you
might be thinking at this point that
Luffy wouldn't really care about all
that stuff and normally I'd say you'd be
right but I think that this version of
Luffy in particular would be exposed to
so many suffering people very early on
in his life that he would also develop a
really strong belief that the world
Nobles are truly evil and all of this
would basically lead to a slightly more
mature version of Luffy I think although
I do have to admit that I can't imagine
Luffy ever being the type of person that
you would want to take on a secrety
mission with you I mean he's not exactly
the sneaky type if you know what I mean
but eventually Luffy Sabo and koala here
would probably be given their very own
missions to recruit new members or even
free oppressed kingdoms however Luffy
even as a revolutionary is still going
to have one massive problem you see in
this scenario Luffy still has his devil
fruit and he was still inspired by
Shanks and of course he still received
his straw hat so deep down he still is
dreaming of becoming a pirate and so
let's say that around the age of 17
similar to in the original story Luffy
just one day decides that it's actually
time now to follow that inner dream of
his now to be fair Dragon might be
absolutely Furious about that and even
want to try and stop Luffy since he now
knows all of the Revolutionary Army
Secrets but eventually I think even
Dragon would let him go I mean he
already basically approved of Luffy
being a pirate in the current storyline
and besides Dragon Sabo would probably
be the most heartbroken because even
though Luffy would probably try to
recruit Sabo and koala to join him on
his journey those two would probably
stick around with the revolutionaries
for now but of course Luffy simply can
set sail on his own at least not
straight from the grand lines so let's
say that the revolutionaries drop him
off back in the East blue and he starts
his journey pretty much like in the
normal story and so while his Adventure
initially is going to start out exactly
the same you're going to be shocked at
how quickly revolutionary Luffy's pirate
Adventure is going to end but first I
still think that he recruits his crew
mates like normal so hop on board
everyone with the only main difference
in the East blue being that Luffy is way
stronger since he now basically already
is pretty decent at hockey so he would
fly through his enemies here freeing The
Villages from the bad guys and his
father would probably be pretty proud
here and even this man here who gave
Luffy his first real defeat would simply
be no match for this hockey and karate
buffed version of Luffy which means that
most of the pre-time skip arcs will
continue like normal although there are
a few super important changes that would
just make too much sense with this more
mature and politically aware Luffy for
example in alabasta Luffy might just
call up Zabo and let him know what is
going on with the Civil War and if the
Revolutionary knew about this they might
even come and help stop the people from
destroying each other alongside Luffy
and the crew which of course would also
be the perfect opportunity for Sabo to
reunite with Ace since Ace as we know
was also briefly present here and that
of course means that Luffy gets to meet
a fiery brother that he never had in
this version which is going to play a
really big role in the story later on
now besides that though there's really
not a whole lot that would change during
the pre-time skip arcs that is of course
until we reach the government island of
enna's Lobby where Luffy and the crew
tried to save Robin from these secret
agents and if we're keeping up with the
idea that Luffy and Sabo are in frequent
contact still then I can see the
revolutionaries taking advantage of the
chaos on the government Island here
maybe they sneak in and steal some
valuable information or something like
that so after the strides rescue Robin
we reach the first major major change
during Luffy's encounter with the former
revolutionary Kuma on thrill bark but
first of all since Luffy is already way
stronger at this point he'd probably
have a very easy time defeating this
shadow guy which means that he will be
awake for the Epic confrontation at the
end of this Arc now I won't get too
heavy into manga spoilers here but um
this scene hits quite a way harder with
what we recently learned about Kuma now
and I cannot even imagine how much it
would break Luffy to see that his friend
Kuma has now been turned into a
government slave but of course we also
now have to ask if Kuma would ever
follow through with his orders and
actually try to kill Luffy don't to be
fair that's even questionable in the
original story because you do have to
remember that for the purposes of this
video Luffy did grow up with the
revolutionaries and would definitely
have known Kuma really really well and
so the warlord here might just straight
up refuse to kill his former friend so
it's entirely possible that we never get
the nothing happen moment in this
version of the story and of course on
top of that I can say that the most
devastating moments in the entire story
would also be very different here
because sabba ODI is the point in the
story where the straw hats truly learn
just how evil the celestial dragons are
and exactly how outmatched they would be
when facing the Admirals and so
considering that this time around Luffy
actually knows about the world Nobles he
might go even further than just punching
this guy and might just straight up kill
this man which is Extreme yeah I know
but revolutionary Luffy has seen a lot
of stuff and is a quite different man
but that's just the first possible
change here because we also simply have
to re-evaluate what would happen at the
end of this Arc because before Luffy and
the crew just straight up did not trust
Kuma at all so when he came in making
everyone disappear there was Major panic
but in this scenario right now Luffy
should be able to figure out pretty
quickly that Kuma is just trying to help
them so instead of absolutely losing
their minds as Kuma sends each member
away they might be a lot more willing to
actually go along with what Kuma was
doing here however that's just a start
of the insanity because now things are
really going to heat up for
revolutionary Luffy because at this
point point I do think that Kuma would
change where he sends Luffy and instead
of landing on Amazon lily as he did in
the original story Luffy instead lands
where he grew up and that's of course at
the Revolutionary army base on the
island of baltigo that's of course
assuming that Kuma knows where the
current base was in baltigo but let's
just imagine that he does so Luffy crash
lands on his father's doorstep which of
course he probably would not like at all
but much more importantly he will very
soon learn about a major world event
that is going to change everything and
that's of course because it is at this
time that the news rapidly spread about
AC's capture and execution date and even
though in this version Luffy did not
grow up with Ace Sabo did for most of
his childhood and I do think that both
of them would absolutely want to free
Ace which does mean that the
revolutionaries are going to suit up for
battle and while Dragon might say that a
full-on assault on imple down is way too
risky I could see them joining the
chaotic War at Marine Fort so do get
ready because Luffy and SA are about to
crash this massive party and while the
thought of dragon just straight up
showing up and fighting at Marine Fort
might be pretty awesome I do think he
might also take just advantage of the
distraction to himself sneak into impul
down himself and free his second in
command Ivanov but back to the war for
now because with Luffy and Sabo here to
fight they quickly team up with the
white bit allies and try to free Ace and
while they don't really think that the
revolutionaries would send their entire
Army here as long as they have a small
small enough squat of powerful Fighters
present like the Revolutionary Army
commanders they should be able to make a
Major Impact in this battle in fact when
you think about it belletti one of the
commander Powers here might just be
perfect for an allout War just like this
since she can encourage the Allies to
fight even harder and pump up their
power with her devil fruit Plus on top
of that with our now's super upgraded
version of Luffy and an equally powerful
Sabo I really think that they are strong
enough to free Ace and survive as well
and since we're already here let's say
that Luffy goes way over the top and
once again declares war on the world
government but this time he says it as a
revolutionary and even plants a
revolutionary flag in front of the
entire Marine forces at Marine Fort
which is going to change everything
because yeah that's right I think at
this point it would be time for Luffy to
rejoin the Revolutionary Army because
with everything that Luffy has seen and
experienced up to this point I do think
that it's very reasonable to think that
he would fully commit to taking down the
world Nobles which yeah would mean
goodbye to the pirate adventure for now
but this Luffy would very likely care
way more about freeing all the oppressed
people in the world as soon as possible
so this change does make a lot of sense
to me which of course also means that
Luffy and Sabo will be permanently
reunited although I'm not really sure if
Luffy would become the new second in
command and bum Sabo down or if they
would just kind of be like co-c in
command or something but the important
thing is that Luffy is back with the
revolutionaries which was the whole
point of this video of course and that
of course would mean that the straw hats
would be joining up as well and it's
honestly kind of nuts to think how
perfectly each of the straw heads dreams
still can be reached once they just stop
being Pirates and become revolutionaries
instead Nami for instance can just still
travel around making her own Maps plus
the revolutionaries probably even have
their own secret stash of maps that she
would just love to explore there also
tons and tons of strong enemies needs to
fight for Zoro to grow as a swordsman
Robin already has ties with the
revolutionaries and Chopper can still
study medicine and so on and so forth as
for Ace I do think he'd probably want to
stick with the Whitebeard Pirates
especially if we assume that the former
Emperor still die during the battle but
even without Ace the revolutionaries
just got a massive power boost because
after some vigorous training for the
straw hats to get stronger we can easily
say that Luffy is now one of the top two
or three fighters in the entire ire
organization Zoro and Sanji are probably
top six or seven if not even higher and
the rest of the crew are huge additions
to the overall strength of the entire
Army and so with this insane jump in
power I could even see the
revolutionaries step up their mission to
take down the celestial dragons and free
oppressed countries in fact the crew
might very well still visit many of the
same Islands as they do in the original
story for example fisherman Island was
about to be taken over by this evil
fishermen so they could use someone to
save them Dres Rosa is still being
oppressed by doflamingo wano had
literally become a wasteland under the
emperor kaido so I could really easily
see Luffy and the revolutionaries still
going to these places to free more
countries and gain a lot more allies
even though Luffy wouldn't have direct
ties with characters like L MOSI at this
point but let's be real in the end it
would just be so fitting if Luffy still
unlocks gear five on wano and his
Advanced conquer hockei during the fight
with kaido since he is a true symbol of
freedom and Liberation at this point but
but of course that also means that all
of this is now leading up to the
undeniable future Clash with the Marines
and the world government and while we're
still waiting to see how that would go I
can just imagine that with all of the
allies of the revolutionaries plus a now
fully awakened Luffy and the crew that
they would be able to take down the
world government and free down the world
maybe even more easily than in the
actual story however that does actually
leave another major problem because
fighting the Marines would put them
directly against family and friends such
as GARP and Luffy's old friend Kobe who
are both going to be incredibly powerful
characters at this point I mean Kobe for
instance went from this wimpy kit to
being an absolute chat for some reason
and now that I'm thinking about it I
kind of wonder what might have happened
if instead of Luffy training with his
father he actually followed his
grandfather's wish to become a Marine so
if you want to see exactly how that
entire scenario would turn out you can
watch that video right here Shanks so
much for watching and I will be seeing
you in the next one